[Music]
our eyes sometimes tend to play tricks
on us with the amount of photoshopped
images online it's even more difficult
to know what's real and what's not
could you believe that someone surfed
waves using their motorcycle get ready
to have your mind blown if you're new to
our channel don't forget to subscribe
and give our video a big thumbs up
because today we'll be sharing 10
pictures you won't believe are in
Photoshop magic faucets your eyes might
look at these floating faucets and think
that someone photoshopped the pipes away
but if you look closer it's just a
clever illusion how do they stay flowing
and where does all the water come from
don't scratch your head too hard because
this magical illusion has a totally
logical explanation these giant floating
faucets have been found
hovering over pools and basins all over
the world from Spain Belgium and the US
they are created with the assistance of
a clear tube in the middle of the water
column that holds the faucet tap up
while sending water up the constant
rushing of water in the tube hides the
water pipe from view and makes us think
these faucets are really floating
Hellboy arm wrestler at first glance the
image of this young man looks like a
very clear case of bad photoshopping
nope this young man is not trying to
impersonate the famous character Hellboy
his arm is in fact very real his name is
matthias schleiden and he was born with
a rare genetic disorder that has caused
the bones in his right forearm to be 33%
larger than the left at 16 years old he
entered a local armwrestling tournament
in Germany and hasn't stopped since the
now 27 year old is a professional
international arm wrestler and has
become a commercial star proving his arm
is very real and very strong venus the
cat one of the most famous kitties on
the internet caused quite a stir one
look at this cat's face will have you
doing a double take the line down
Venus's face is almost perfectly split
down the middle one half of her face is
solid black with a green eye and the
other half is orange striped with a blue
her famous tagline is 0% Photoshop 100%
foreign this way but how is it possible
that this cat is real people believe
that she may have contained two
different types of DNA but it turns out
it was all just luck how cool is that
Beach runway if you think this is a
screenshot from the next blockbuster
movie you are wrong this is no joke and
if you don't believe us
just take a trip to the Caribbean island
of st. Maarten and visit the Maho beach
it is located directly next to the
Princess Juliana International Airport
tourists from around the world gather
for the experience of a lifetime most of
the restaurants and bars even display
the daily arrivals and departures
airline timetables
the planes fly but only meters from
their heads and if you don't hold on to
your stuff or even yourself you could be
blown away by the immense jet force I
guess that's one way to dry yourself off
Goat tree these goats are not a product
of a funny Photoshop prank and no they
are not excitedly pretending to be
Christmas ornaments the goats really are
standing on the branches of an argan 'ya
tree PR Jennea is a rare and protected
species of tree that is grown almost
exclusively in Morocco the tree produces
an incredibly delicious fruit that
attracts tons of goats and other hungry
animals they swarm to the Argan 'ya
branches and go to great lengths to
reach the sweet fruit how far would you
go for your favorite tasty snack Haku
the fish this fish caught the attention
of many people when it began turning up
in rivers and lakes across the US and
it's easy to see why it might be hard to
believe but this image has not been
tampered with this fish is known as a
PACU fish and really does have human
looking teeth the PACU is a native of
the Amazon River in South America and is
a close relative of the piranha much
like humans apophis teeth are mostly
used to grind down food their powerful
jaws and teeth are great for cracking
nuts that fall from trees but we still
wouldn't want them taking a bite of our
ankles the crooked house this
wonderfully wonky structure looks like
someone was having a little too much fun
in Photoshop this adorable house is
called chef Adamic which translates into
Crooked House it is located in sulphate
Poland and was built by a design team
known as a tin ski and Zaleski in 2004
the 4000 square metre commercial
building is attached to a shopping
centre tourists constantly flocked to
see one of the world's strangest
buildings Crooked House was built to
honour the children's book and fairy
tale book illustrations by Yann Shan sir
we love this real-life fairy tale
building don't you floating whale this
floating creature would be the last
thing on your mind when you and your
friends go to the beach sure you expect
seaweed to attack you or someone to dive
under the water and grab your foot
pretending to be a sea monster but you
definitely don't expect the largest
mammal in the ocean to surf to the shore
with you what this crowd and you are
witnessing is a disease whale floating
close to the shore be careful though you
might just get chunks of whale blubber
on you because whales are known to
explode due to the large amounts of gas
buildup band of ants all right so out of
all the photos so far this one is
definitely the most out there for
unbelievable what a colony of ants
banded together to unscrew a soda cap
and place a straw inside and if so how
could anyone happen to be in the right
place at the right time to snap this pic
this has to be a heavily CGI'd Superbowl
commercial right wrong this is actually
the mastermind of Andre Pavlov a former
set designer for the entertainment
industry he designed this incredible set
piece along with many others so he could
interact with the ants and snap these
award-winning shots seeing ants work
together at this scale is awe-inspiring
to Andre and we agree
motorcycle surfing this image is a bad
attempt at a clearly photoshopped image
surfing with a dirt bike seems as
impossible as this image don't you think
believe it or not this extreme image is
no optical illusion or computer trick it
is a product of professional motorbike
rider and
runnin junkie Robbie Maddison he is
known for pushing boundaries like
jumping across an open Tower Bridge in
London and jumping the Arc de Triomphe
replica in Las Vegas in the spirit of
pushing boundaries he bolted ski
attachments on his dirtbike and tackle
the ocean waves pretty unbelievable
isn't it
which of these photos did you find hard
to believe leave us a comment down below
and let us know if you'd like to see
more cool videos like this one don't
forget to subscribe to the things thanks
for watching
[Music]
you